marvel studios loki has introduced a
whole new variant on everyone's favorite
god of mischief
with the mysterious sylvie running
around the timeline with loki in tow
the mcu is getting weirder than it's
ever been before
here are the easter eggs you missed and
loki episode 3.
much of loki episode 3 is spent on
lamentis 1
a rocky purple skied moon facing
imminent destruction
the episode is even named after lamentis
which has briefly appeared in marvel
comics
debuting in 2007's annihilation conquest
prologue number one
it lies on the outskirts of cree space
that appearance is basically just
dimension which means that for all
intents and purposes lamentus one is
basically a blank slate for the marvel
cinematic universe a perfect spot for
loki to continue delving into its
narrative mysteries in other words
loki and sylvia arrive on lament one
after escaping from ravana and her
minutemen following a skirmish outside
the elevator doors leading to the
timekeepers
they land on the moon in 2077 12 hours
before it's set to collide with its
planet
an inconvenient apocalypse for them to
hide in but with their temped low on
juice this odd couple of loki's is
forced to make the best of a bad
situation
not the only tech savvy loki don't ever
call me that
tech savvy no a loki after sylvie and
loki sneak on board the shuttle
ferrying ticket holders off lamentus 1
they have time to start getting to know
one another
so naturally talk turns to their love
lives sylvie remains as cagey as
ever but tells loki she's managed to
keep a long-distance relationship going
with a postman as she runs from one
apocalypse to another
managed to maintain quite a serious
long-distance relationship with a
post-man
whilst running across time from one
apocalypse to another at first this
sounds like a joke
as if she could maintain any kind of
relationship given her current life path
but as it turns out there's more than
one postman of note in marvel comics
that fans may know about
first appearing in 2002's morlock's
number one
postman aka david is a mutant who lost
control of his powers and
accidentally wiped his wife's mind he
seeks refuge with the morlocks based in
chicago and eventually becomes their
leader postman ends up losing his mutant
abilities thanks to the scarlet witch
whose no more mutants decree in 2005's
house of m
number seven wipes the mutant gene from
the vast majority of its carriers
of course sylvie and postman don't
appear to have a clear connection in the
comics so we'd say put a pin
in this one it's not necessarily a hint
that the postman character is coming
but across the movies and tv shows of
phase 4 the mcu
is clearly setting up something and
it'll be hard to know what were real
hints and what were just coincidences
until the series lays all its cards on
the table multiverse
mutants who knows another famous postman
is willie lumpkin
the friendly mailman most known for his
appearances in the fantastic four comic
books
and also for dating mae parker and the
amazing spider-man
so who knows maybe sylvie had a thing
for him there may look like there's a
bit of an
age gap but these are loki's we're
talking about looks can be deceiving
or maybe sylvie really is just pining
for a hunky delivery man she's never
been able to settle down with
it wouldn't be the first time in
asgardian super being has fallen for a
regular joe
or jane we are treated to some fun
callbacks to earlier mcu chapters in
loki and episode 3 is no exception
once loki and sylvie work their way onto
the lamentis shuttle they sit and
converse in one of its upper scale
lounges
as they talk loki helps himself to two
glasses of champagne
and silvie ends up falling asleep when
she wakes her new travel companion has
treated himself to more beverages
and he's putting on a show for the other
travelers in the lounge
after singing and giving cheers to
sylvie loki smashes a martini glass and
yells
mcu fans will notice this nod to the
first thor film
the line and gesture are uttered by thor
when he visits a diner with his new
earth pals jane foster eric selvig and
darcy lewis
it's drink i like it i know it's great
right
the line is one of the most quoted from
the original thor movie which feels
so long ago at this point all of these
characters have been through so much at
this point
it's nice that the mcu can still slow
down and show that it remembers where it
came from
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you